hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to off now I apologize
for the gap in between the episodes here
I have some problem recording it I got a
little bit ahead and then apocalypse
just happened chaos rain from the sky
meteor was falling fire everywhere women
and children were running screaming to
the woods everything was a fireball
everyone is gonna die and then my
recording failed which just happened to
happen at the same time so I went a
little bit ahead here I saw these lovely
little guys aren't they just the most
adorable creatures University no they
give you nightmares well why would they
they're so cute we're all with you be
nice okay they're dead I guess I killed
him Phil so oh yeah I forgot
boring Orville her holding all of
herself Oh ring Orville and onion ring
Oliver sorry I'm having trouble with
these manger um Orville actually has
some curing abilities and buffs and what
not are not buffs but you know what I
mean he has a curing ability and then he
has this attack that does a random
amount of damage so I don't know much
about him but I'm hoping that when he
levels up he's like my white mage and
he's able to heal and resurrect I mean I
mean the batter is able to heal but
maybe spreading it around a little bit
would be nice but either way I didn't
get very far I just got into this area
and I started to see these lovely
manikin guys standing around and staring
at me in blendable fashion and oh look
it's the little rats there's one enemy
here that you guys are just gonna go
nuts for because I lost my mind the
first time that I shot so does eagerly
await cuz I know he's gonna be coming
any moment now bye-bye little rat see
inhale stay there next time purification
waits for no man the batter has no time
for your silly antics the batter must
find his way out of here the batter must
escape your maze the battle must stop
referring to himself in the third person
so that the batter can lead a normal
life and maybe then the batter can stop
purifying everybody that he sees now I
think I need to go here hello
hi I'm lost you need purification I
could make a fire with the boxes the
sword of the ghost and that would be too
dangerous
you know as dangerous a bat to the
temple which is the side of your head
and it would probably came in your skull
so anything else in here than I need why
are you in here
Oh support in this room fine carry on
citizen your purification will wait
another day the baton has more important
things to do all right so I haven't
found it yet
God why haven't I found that cool enemy
then I know you guys are gonna like
hello
don't pieces of silver flesh have been
found good more competence points from
me
hello I can't kitty are you doing which
kitty are you oh you're the weird kitty
all right hello is this where I'm
supposed to be hi are you the other
kitty is not this publicity surf active
and efficient whilst defying the basics
of consumer marketing for silkier hair
the meat founders of all MA oh good just
dip your hair in the meat rivers they'll
be fine oh you can read anyway I'm glad
to have found you maybe you can help me
unravel the mystery that Vedas place
before me it turns out that my brother
has been living in this area for many
years here's a special affinity for
colors of the cool guy unfortunately
I've so far failed to cross his path
well he's kind of right outside the door
I have tried to betake myself to the
roof of the library where he resides
however I found the door closed even the
long hours of intensive repeated knowing
and compulsive scratching did not do a
thing
my request is that follows if at the
bend of a corridor you happen to see
Valerie give him my greetings his name
is Valerie okay oh that's why I like the
batter straight to the point
no fooling about the battery ah hello I
get it picked out out
I got a potato where's the Potala though
um okay wait a minute I am I actually
done here I'm actually done in this area
here I saw the cat okay and I all must
be outside I'm guessing that it would be
on the Overlook that the people were
looking over to the other eras hello mr.
Badal oh I'll make you woo I can take
you out into the ocean uh oh oh oh my
god where am I taking you mr. Padano
where are we going hello
I did nothing wrong oh where am I going
what in the world am i doing where's my
Padano going okay well well I was weird
I think I want to be out of this ocean
now I think there might be like some
sort of Easter egg out here oh my oh I
found it I was about to say you guys
could write in the comments below I try
to find you later
when I find a minwoo tunic whoa oh sorry
minwu whoa minwu tunic was it really
good oh to moderate upgrade what was the
point of that I was finding something
really secret ah come on I thought it
was gonna be oh that's it I thought it
was gonna be something spectacular I
guess it was pretty cool anyway that
whispering why was that whispering that
was the same whispering that's from the
oh oh I popped it a fortune ticket has
been found I have I guess that's good
okay hello from here maybe 74 minutes
am I about to go on a roller coaster am
I about to go oh you guys never saw
anything oh my god I hope the enemy is
coming sometime later because oh it's
not too cool enemy you guys have to see
it oh my god to tuzik between three
attractions is it's too difficult for me
okay that's all you have to say danger
do not approach the pools of plastic why
not what's wrong with them what's wrong
with the pools of plastic
hey water in a room it's a really crazy
concept we are definitely in a park okay
what does that even spell oh hi with
well well come play play play the
balloon game if you win you get the
grand prize but if you if you lose you
might be you sad so be careful oh boy
play the balloon game of course okay
here are the rules it's easy
well it's your turn you can choose to
pop one two or three balloons when is my
turn all is the same the one who's left
with the last balloon loses the game
wait a minute what oh so okay I get it I
got it okay let's start alternate first
bubble ski okay so you pop okay
so let me think about this I'm gonna get
this on the first try guys don't worry
about this I've been a pot turbulence
too
well here's my turn okay so whoever's
left with the last balloon wins so well
that's easy I just need to pop two
yeah I got this I did it
yeah I'm a genius it probably wasn't now
that's impossible
I've been cheating from the start yeah
cheated you barely said you will oh
hello
oh we're fighting oh my god what is
wrong with you why do you have a symbol
around your weirdo neck well time to be
R value
you look very unfix that problem yep Oh
dope take that
by the way that poison attack I never
noticed that it actually does do numbers
there's like over time so I need to keep
that in mind when I do that cuz it's a
very very useful ability to keep the
poison rolling in between my fans I got
a necktie whoa what do I do with it no
well then oh god what did I do
the grand prize is a necktie I'm sod
what are you running from
Vanek wait worth it I'm scared
I say that's good okay I didn't even
talk to you I didn't play should've
closed this place is far too dangerous
far too much okay I'm sorry
I can't get through this wall that goes
believe me stop trying are you guys
doing
our there and he goes here it still
sounds pretty fun and happy it's over
here hello this is the bosses office I
cannot let you enter unless maybe you
know him personally but without prove I
hear I can't like in trouble okay oh yay
badal Oh what do you do meet your Padano
with it boy these motors are placed
underwater to guide the picado
very nice oh oh oh I get it I see I see
so to be able to do this I need to hit
certain ones ah okay I got you
oh no no no no no no go back no come on
let me know okay well I already cocked
that one up so I missed out on that
balloon so fortunate ticket god that's a
big heal thing I need to do that okay so
can I see
I can't you're not gonna let me see what
I'm oh come on no no no wait I can go
back I can go back yeah there is really
hard to see but there are pass four
pieces of belial is meat
yay miles meat is the tastiest when I
put it in my mouth and chomp it up not
damn it this is gonna be a guessing game
how am i suppo bing bong baba bong yeah
I don't know what the rules are for how
fast those go and how far but I seem to
be winning a loyal cymbal I think I
already have those for my guys up up oh
there we go okay no no no no no no no no
oh I see I need it on the outside
alright so now oh yeah oh there's a
switch up there okay so oh god I didn't
say it stop it god I'm not this stupid
you stop making me out to be like a
giant idiot but didn't they say that
there's spectres in the park I didn't
see any I thought I was flip the switch
okey dokey I got it don't know it's not
dead but way I'm gonna go back man that
must have been a to program for
the guy who ever made this cuz that does
not seem like it was easy to organize
which way those would go hep hep an
inspiration has been found good I needed
that
yay back home I know I missed one but
I'm not gonna go all the way back
through that just to get that so allows
fun and all what do I do now
I've flipped a switch what do a dual at
all hello I wanna see that share I'm
just waiting for him to finish whatever
you're doing do you want me to use my
back to purify him I feel like I've
gotta love it
that wouldn't be careful at all oh so
you're waiting a minute okay you're
waiting for him to mom are you guys on a
ride I'd rather look out here this trash
this looks to daredevil is for me
oh it's less scary like this I'm afraid
to get up okay you weirdos this is the
way the old roller coaster closed Alba
where it was even complete okay so did
this which turn that on do hello who are
you
I thought the roller coaster they closed
town but how did you get here
if you ride it you have the right to get
a photo hey hey I get a ride roller
coaster oh happy I'm a riot there's
gonna be no oh hello it's a statue is
accurate push oh okay
can i push him okay I prefer to take the
seat in front oh good for you batter
this statue dude oh it said it was a
statue of the owner oh I need to get a
picture with him but target here oh oh
that's right cuz the guy to the office
he said he needed me to get a picture
with him oh here's your photo your photo
of you has been found let's see this
hope it's not terrifying
well batters alright fine
the batteries of zilla's love me okay
enough silliness the batter's
purification quiz does not have enough
time for your ridiculousness why would I
want to put a statue on roller coaster
anyway so I'm assuming I need to push
him with me yeah yeah yeah yeah all
right that's right a roller coaster my
brain is working so much into overtime
I'm connecting whoa I'm kiddin do it so
I'm connecting all the pieces of the
puzzle together my brain aren't you guys
happy with me Oh easy photo photo of
Zachary's but wait well here lucky you
wrote it with the owner yeah I did I
sure did haha I look moderately
terrified ah but there if there's the
owner all right honey I'm so proud of
myself even though I brought you to me
because it's probably really easy
puzzles to solve you guys are still
panicking really okay whatever
these are probably really easy puzzles
to solve and I shouldn't be too proud of
myself
uh
the Lib Lib la is that a photo of the
boss and you right next to him a
rollercoaster that's terribly dangerous
well any right I guess you're a friend
of the boss you man oh boy ah so you the
boss
you should ride our Eliquis look it
happen the statue could come to life and
Gillman adores orb a Libra orb a Scorpio
orb ah
verg orb a Capricorn orb and gem Minori
orb
okey-dokey what of those do for us oh oh
yeah what's a spirit oh these are but I
know what those are I'm gonna use these
on the batter because you guys are nice
and all Oliver and Orville I appreciate
what you do but there's a head honcho
over here so maybe you should just let
me do why didn't the secret that I found
on the island give me those no clip-on
awesome uh whatever it is what it is and
it is what it is and it is what it ain't
so I'm gonna go this way I'm gonna go
all the way back to the bank take my rap
game to a whole nother level and then
probably shut up because my rap game is
awful everybody actually I'm pretty sure
that if I ever tried to pursue a career
as a rapper might like my idol Marky
Mark I would not do too well duh let's
just stick with the youtubing that seems
to be working out just fine let's just
say oh yeah I remember
okay so I have a next time and I got a
bunch of buffs so is there another place
here that I haven't been no this is shop
see this is the Oh what's this area have
I been here before have I been here I
think I have been her stranger not
wearing a tie have I been here I don't
remember this it's been a few days as I
played I don't remember if I been here
these barriers prevent people from
falling into the plastic there if
they're even made us huh harmless rubber
sorry forgot the focus for a second
that's good
the residential areas for resin is all
about to the paddock of entries
everything I die I die oh oh I have a
type oh I have a type necktie yes I can
put my tie on here good idea
yes the doors have opened for me oh yes
oh let's look at it look at all this
monotonous playing glory hello
what do we have here oh oh oh I don't
remember what this guy's voices um hang
on Zane there is still time to repent to
your own missions I'm grateful wretches
crave my pardon immediately or I will
send you back to limbo this instant did
you hear some pork friends I am here
right in front of you ready to send you
to hell so are you ready to apologize to
your father and protector you band of
wimps there's there's nothing but an old
cat up there it could be a dangerous cat
and as sharp claws yes it it spreads
disease have you heard the story of the
guy who got scratched by a cat ah I hate
you I hate you all then where's that
like a Libra bass piece how it is in a
bear
yes II should take the time to relax and
enjoy this place so fine and quiet here
who wears a but that was me it was I who
made it all live after you are you all
so blinded by a pathetic fear of living
this is all rather strange isn't it I'm
going to teach you to respect me I
really don't remember
oh hello that's a lot of ghost egos I
have to save them I have to purify the
spirits and save the citizens of this
world let's burst these impure beasts
and fast I have a time limit oh crap now
what's in here door opens with a code I
don't have a code no idea what's the
code I always was it oh oh hello you
bulbous freak you I'm going to purify
the crap out of you yep yeah never die
yeah yeah the series purified you don't
know management boy had a joker I think
that resurrects people there are seven
phantoms remaining in the area I must
hurry
I must expeditiously purify these poor
wretches hello is there any purification
required in this building ah yes I
thought sir prepare to be perfect good
thing that the timer doesn't go through
the battle because out not bode well for
me and up boom yeah suck on way you know
no oh that's hardly fair well what am I
supposed to do about that okay I guess I
didn't do my stronger attack I didn't
kill him before he did that okay there's
another down now unbiased us okay that's
going well
you probably save up all my CP so they
don't spend it trying to kill each oh
well that didn't do anything how we stop
that don't be such dick is this one not
dying there we go finally oh my god that
took forever I gotta kill him way before
they do that Jesus all right so there's
a door with a code and I'm guessing that
I'm gonna be able to find the code it's
somewhere in the city but I don't know
if I'm gonna have time to do it before I
need to get out of one ain't no vibrant
right there yeah 105 perfect Oh perfect
one 805 don't forget that everybody
god dammit I did a god devil us
blend oh okay good now I just need to
stop screwing up but now I can go back
stopped it yeah 1 805 1 805 ok I can go
back there I can open that up find a
secret or another phantom that I
actually needed I don't know which one
it is all running out of time one okay
it all 5 but um I open it no no no don't
do this to me oh come on God
uh-oh come on maybe there's another door
in here maybe there's multiple doors I
have no goddamn idea but you're gonna be
purified all right God God yes get out
here you son of a yeah okay all
right okay there's another building that
I can enter in here maybe this guy's
secret in it you you give me a code give
me a code what screw you I don't care
about fighting you please tell me you
pity me not really when I'm in a hurry
you son of a what do I have a coat
if it's not gonna work
stupid decent booby ah what no stop
completion your weight all over me I'm
trying to save you people you're not get
this do not understand things I do
hey that's deserve this yeah you did you
could loose your brain all over me and
I'm not yet oh another door oh oh wait a
minute there's nothing in here there's a
chest
Boldin flesh oh that does care no no no
no okay that's right don't try to find
me broad I'd kick your ass in a
millisecond you get to die an early
death don't cause me any trouble how's
the wrong a door he's dead
three more two minutes eh no no problem
yeah oh there's another one over there
I'm is that good oh they just check to
see if there's now I'm hiding out down
there up now that I can say time to die
you son of a we're better meter
hang on let me see what's up here okay
what's in here anything in there you
what are you doing up there
code Oh will there be non-zero where Oh
God
running at a time southwest bunker one
402 what for are you okay so that's cool
I got that one well I don't know if I
have time for anything else
ah oh there's the last one over there
man I might be able to run and get the
other one yeah there we go you're dead
you son of a
good job thank you okay I might have
enough time I might have another time
one 402 1 402 a 1 402 oh oh yeah oh yeah
going very far going very fast doing
nothing shoving them up my ass are
killed
oh yeah be found oh I came over thank
you what are you doing get out my way go
my way
son of a stop trying to stand
between me and my prize I will verify
you wait there's a there's a question
that I have why do these normal ordinary
citizens turn into these weird monsters
it's very strange that they get on girl
like that
here the way got it get out of my way Oh
terrible thing too bad a Michael bad Oh
Twitter yeah I think maybe okay gotta
get back gotta get back get back
uh-huh wanna kill everybody I'm not even
gonna try to get the last one I'm not
gonna risk losing all this yeah I get
there you're dead you're done son
Oh God does he have enough okay I think
he has enough see boom boom get out of
here that's right knocked you right out
of the park
yes I got y'all phantoms have been
purified all the birds have been
purified a sundae has been found all the
burns has been purified cuz I mean I
killed all the guys there turned into
weird I bare fide this place but this
vows own has not yet been freed of its
true best where can I find Jaffa Jaffa
no zoos alpha the cat who directs uh
specters uh-huh the cat IIIi don't know
anyway we thank you for helping us but
uh nothing yeah there my bad
yes if we your bad huh that's an awfully
dangerous objects I'll have to ask you
to leave the residential area and give
us your tie what you should understand
of course it's the bedroom security Oh
dare you I dare you hello judge how are
you doing I am embarrassed I admit but
it appears that I need you and your
puppets purifying intention dear mock
blow Valerie my beloved brother appears
to have fallen off the rails of
consciousness and into the depths of
uncontrollable madness it calls himself
Javed and in addition to be the Royal
agent he is never been proclaims himself
chief of the spectres till roles he has
usurped no doubt
nobody in this world I can assure you
has any control over the ectoplasm
except pops a queen but I have yet to
find any concrete evidence so testimony
to prove this hypothesis anyway
Valerie is settled on the roof of the
library and although I suppose this
could have been just a coincidence it
seems a ghost just swarming the
corridors of the same building I believe
this is a perfect mission for you full
of all that gratuitous violence which
you seem to revel with glee okay I'll go
to the library I will follow me oh
you're following me
is he a new body member oh no he's out
there okay I the first second I thought
I was gonna have a kitty cat as a body
member not a parent he does not want to
join the party all right then fine
how you doing a man it seems a new
residential area has been attacked by
fact earth
I don't dare go there ever had wimp
baby baby wimpy wimpy who's a big ol
baby whip oh you're with me baby you're
Oh every baby wimp okay so what I needed
here now is that I need to return to the
land of the spectres and defeat this is
offered so that he knows not to ever
mess with me ever again and we shall see
who truly is the
of this adventure of the specters yes we
shall oh I will venture my way up this
decade is who hello there's a bookshelf
with a psycho drawing from his waning
forces he created the library more
beautiful than ever before his eyes
pisses smoky clouds and Bay's good one
in four I'm gonna have to write those
down on I son of a run on a bunny
r14 1-4 draw yay I love writing down
clues
it's the oh hello look at that parallax
scrolling it's beautiful what climbing
the tower our night much like a guardian
angel he had done everything for them he
had brought them peace security and
entertainment was such was is the rosin
e29 moving on I got a read all this
don't I probably I do for a while that
was all good and well for all they
enjoyed the new land with the innocence
of a child
they were running down the streets
enjoying
3:9 but the dynamics of the world soon
draw the people man they forgot about
their joys a eventually succumbed to
their neuroses of fear and worries they
weren't for soon meanwhile the flaming
wings sovereign weeped on his throne
their choice and to have been forgotten
by her here no more time for their
worries 5 1 all right keep climbing the
tower I really hope you guys see the
enemy cuz you guys haven't seen it it's
gonna be so worth it when you see it
absolutely Mumbai turned into a cat and
the cat into a ruler driven insane by
his anger and sadness he summoned for
the storm of evil spirits upon his
subjects his madness had 6 6
while the Sveta's were destroying the
world he is created
he sought shelter at the summit of his
wonderful creation the Great Library I
don't have the energy to keep doing that
voice oh look another lovely area up
here in the sky
whoa thank you ah the whale oh you guys
haven't seen the whale virtu killed so
dead but ah this is the enemy wait have
you guys seen this before I don't know
of you guys now I don't even care of you
guys had ah the whale oh I don't
remember anything anymore
it's so weird playing these series and
not remembering oh hello another whale
space whale you're like floating off the
edge of the tower of all I did not
care whatever I'll kill you anyway
honk honk Dan
dead good job Whaley soil
oh don't you know boy oh oh I know this
there was nothing else yeah there's
nothing else to be done but wait for the
man who would rise forth to destroy him
for deep inside his soul there was no
doubt that what he did was evil
the end eight-zero so I noticed a
pattern rights 1 through 4 so I'm
supposed to say four nine nine seven one
six one wait no no no no oh I did
it wrong four nine nine seven one six
four zero bottle ski I got it I'm the
Bears well no more books to read thank
goodness I didn't want to read them
anymore okay oh yay I'm about to fight
the boss oh I'm about to fight the boss
hell's chilly yeah you guys are gonna
lie this one I think I'm gonna kill a
bird nice feel from up here total ink it
almost makes me forget this zone video
okay I'll do this in the meantime it's
time to end this episode unfortunately I
hope you guys aren't doing off because I
know I said Liam also why are there
boogers dripping down that tower very
strange so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I played in the past long
series short theories one offs anything
I've got a ton of them thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye
sounds up on the moon cycle answer your
Oh God now are you attacking deposited